dieses ist ein jahr alt werde c't du das
essen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
würdest du das essen
ich glaube nicht warum denkst du nicht
das ist siegen geht schon schade dass
ich irgendwann mal was verraten
das ist ein ganz parteien jahre alte
eier gegessen
[Musik]
wenn man mich fragt da gibt es nichts
besseres als jeden tag frische eier von
unserem hineinzuholen jetzt ist aber die
zeit in der die wiener richtig gas geben
und im winter haben sie denn ihre lege
pause und dann bekommen wir monatelang
fast gar keine eier und deswegen nehmen
wir den überschuss den wir jetzt haben
und nach innen für den winter haltbar
und zwar ohne kühlung oder einkochen
einfach so wie die eier sind und wie das
funktioniert das zeige ich euch heute
achtet immer darauf dass sie nur saubere
eier verwendet und auch nur die eier vom
selben tag haltbar macht das hier wären
wir schon ein bisschen zu dreckig wer
hinter der kennt das wahrscheinlich dass
wenn es draußen ein bisschen matschig
ist oder wenn die netbox nicht ganz
sauber ist dass die eier dann auch nicht
so ganz sauber sind und deswegen die
nächste boxen auf jeden fall immer schön
sauber halten wir müssten die sogar noch
öfter aus als den stein
einige von euch werden jetzt
wahrscheinlich sagen aber aber man kann
im winter doch einfach licht anmachen im
stall und der legen die hühner trotzdem
weiter und die tage einfach so künstlich
verlängern
wir machen das nicht weil wir uns an
hühnern die ruhepause einfach absolut
können sie legen das ganze jahr über so
viele tolle feier für uns dass sie sich
im winter ruhig mal ein bisschen
ausruhen können und deswegen sorgen wir
einfach selber vor und machen jetzt
rechtzeitig genug einhaltbar damit wir
dann im winter immer noch unsere eigenen
eier essen können
das ist ja auch irgendwelche eier für
mich diese klar und ich verloren zum
mikrofon
die müssen wir das jetzt so richtig
professionell machen sich das tier ein
bisschen verstecken
jetzt brauchen wir jetzt nichts ist ein
topf in denen kein licht rein kommt hier
gibt es mal gerade darum an sohn gert
hof oder steigen die top die sind nur
verdammt weit oben auf dem schrank man
hat es nicht leicht als kleiner mensch
[Musik]
hallo du jetzt mache ich aus der zukunft
ich schneide gerade an dem video wendet
sich das extra gemacht hätte bald ihr
kriegt immer die volle marie portion ab
normalerweise schneide ich sowas immer
raus aber das bleibt jetzt einfach drin
und so eben so bin ich und so werde das
ganze abende ganz normal ein kochtopf
mißbrauchen wir lösch kalk um die eier
haltbar zu machen wir haben ein kleines
problem wir sind ja gerade umgezogen vor
ein paar wochen monaten eigentlich schon
vor lange her aber wenn man noch nicht
alle kisten ausgepackt und ich habe
keine ahnung wo der löschteich geblieben
ist
ich schätze er es unten in unserem
völlig zugemüllten keller ich hoffe
deswegen überhaupt finden sonst ist das
einzige völlig umsonst gewesen was im
chaos
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob die da drin war das
der einzige stadt irgendwie sinn ergeben
würde war der ist so ein wort
[Musik]
denn ich möchte meinen freund eine
ahnung vielleicht noch irgendwo in der
speisekammer kommen wir ihnen nochmal
suchen
das zeug ist hier nicht ich weiß auch
nicht wo jetzt noch suchen soll ich
meine wir könnten den ganzen keller
ausräumen aber das würde wahrscheinlich
tage dauern
deswegen gehen wir jetzt einfach im
baumarkt und kaufmann es nochmal welches
aber wir geben nicht auf in sachen eine
krankenkasse soll ich denn jetzt einfach
im internet hierbei lokale einzelhandel
ich hab versucht dich zu unterdrücken
sie beschreiben sagt meisten textilien
angekommen werden die kunden vergaben
zunächst uns fragen da aber ich kann
damit jetzt unseren löschen und dann
nehmen wir davon zwei esslöffel auf
einen liter wasser wie geht das ding
hier auf
[Musik]
ich hab's geschafft zwei esslöffel darin
gar nicht so einfach eine ein liter
wasser und umrühren
ich zeige euch das mal kurz clubs und da
ein kam jetzt die eier und zwar so dass
sie mit der spitze nach unten zeigen
aber am anfang wenn man gerade erst die
ersten eier 1 legt man so ja immer nur
die frischen eier vom selben tag nehmen
da hat man noch nicht so viele auch
sagen hat super viele hühner dann kugeln
die noch ein bisschen im eimer um das
heißt erst in den nächsten tagen wenn
mehr eier dazu kommen dann können wir
alle ja so hinlegen dass sie mit der
spitze nach unten zeigen dass es
übrigens auch wenn man da ja frisch
lagert die beste haltung für die er
selber auch immer getan oder einer
karussell gelang in unserer gerne so die
eier mit der spitze nach unten lägen
mein freund macht das nie und ich
schimpfe in jeden tag dafür
er hat es nicht leicht mit mir da kommen
dann einfach jeden tag immer die
frischen eier dazu ich nehme dafür
einfach immer die sauberen eier wenn wir
dreckiger kriegen dann essen wir die
frisch und so passt das eigentlich immer
ganz gut dass wir in seinen überschuss
dann hier drin haltbar machen und in bar
wochen ist dieser topf dann voll und
wenn die flüssigkeit irgendwann nicht
mehr ausreicht und die eier oben aus der
flüssigkeit rausschauen sollten dann
einfach wieder die gleiche mischung
nehmen zwei esslöffel pro liter wasser
und das ganze auffüllen bis alle eier
schön bedeckt sind
einen richtigen deckel drauf wo haben
wir den
dann kennen wir das ganze einfach so im
küchenschrank lagern genauso wie die
eier sind die meisten von euch werden
wahrscheinlich eigene hühner haben und
deswegen die eier haltbar machen wollen
wenn ihr jetzt aber auf die idee kommt
dass mit gekauften eier zu machen dann
würde ich eher davon abraten weil es ist
zwar verboten dass man gekaufte eier
selbst also das ist gesetzlich einfach
nicht erlaubt aber ich hab selber schon
sehr viel auf dem bauernhof bearbeitet
und die dreckigen eier verkaufen sich
einfach schlecht und deswegen werden in
der praxis super viele eier trotzdem
gewaschen und dadurch geht die
schutzschicht die die eier
natürlicherweise haben kaputt und keime
können in das innere eindringen so dass
man die nicht mehr einlagern oder halber
machen sollte ich weiß nicht ob das ein
muss ist aber wir verwenden die eier die
wir haltbar machen und dann im winter
essen nur hart gekocht das heißt so ein
halb flüssiges frühstücksei machen wir
aus denen dann nicht mehr da warten mit
ein lieber bis zum frühling bis wir
wieder richtig schön frische eier haben
das hier sind eier die wir noch von
letztem jahr übrig haben sehen genauso
aus wie normale eier nur dass die schale
vielleicht ein bisschen rauer ist ich
verstehe immer ab bevor ich die verbände
und die dinge selbst schon über ein jahr
alt aber die werden sicher noch total
lecker sein
[Musik]
dollar
der 1
[Musik]